je ne peux pas commencer à se dire
bonjour à tout le monde donc mesdames
messieurs et surtout les jeunes
je vous remercie d'être là je remercie
aussi les organisateurs qui rompent qui
m'ont invité à cet événement c'est du
bon boulot ma formation de base je vous
le cache pas parce que peut-être vous
avez vu ça je suis un agronome
après j'ai fait un doctorat à
l'université catholique de louvain les
très longtemps il a plus que 30 ans
puisse travailler comme chercheur dans
le système national
après ça j'ai quitté le système national
pour aller travailler dans dans un
centre international qui s'occupe d'eux
des pays arides
c'est le centre international des
recherches agricoles dans les zones
arides
je vous le dis déjà le cactus n'est pas
n'est pas mon travail mais c'est mon
hobby c'est mon passe temps et je rejoue
à l'animateur quand il vous dit fait
surtout les choses que vous aimez bon je
me suis intéressé lui vous présenter ce
qu'on a pu faire avec ça près donc assez
rapidement et pour venir
c'est important de faire ce qu'on aime
si on se met à faire des choses qu'on
n'a pas ce sera mal fait avec ça j'ai
terminé on peut commencer
l'intitulé de
de ma contribution et comme mon
transfert mais le drapeau de la misère
en une source de richesse
c'est un titre provocateur dans le monde
40% de la superficie de la planète et
aride vous et moi nous vivons dans un
pays aride dans six pays aride les 40%
il y à 2,5 millions de gens qui vivent
16% de ces deux virus lors de ses 2 5
millions d'individus sont en dessous du
seuil de la pauvreté
donc là où il ya la réalité est là la
pauvreté le futur malheureusement ça ne
s'annonce pas glorieux toutes les
prévisions en termes de changements
climatiques disent qu'on va assister à
une réduction de la pluviométrie de 20 à
30%
nous sommes dans la zone des 30 % ce
bonhomme qui est dans le pot à côté de
moi ça c'est un cactus pour ce que le
savent pas il ne vient pas de chez nous
son histoire va trop loin alvin avec la
déco quai avec la découverte des
amériques et il a fallu attendre en 1519
cortès dans une des expéditions espagnol
dans les îles et west indies les
caraïbes actuellement il a trouvé une
plante bizarre et surtout il a trouvé
des individus des personnes qui ramasse
et des insectes sur ces plantes
il faisait sécher ces insectes les
broyer et les tubes et les utiliser
comme un colorant et la ramener ce
colorant en espagne en 1519 et il a
amené aussi le premier plan de cactus et
de la la dissémination a commencé
un peu partout en chine vers 1700 en
inde en afrique du sud etc
ce sont les marins qui ont fait la
diffusion de son équipe donc de ce
cactus pourquoi tous les marins et vous
l'avez appris à l'école souffrait du
scorbut qui est une déficience en
vitamine et le cactus et les très riches
en vitamines et le conserver dans les
cales des bateaux et à chaque fois qu'il
descendait dans un pays il m'était une
raquette pour quand ils reviennent ils
peuvent l'utiliser et le consommer c'est
comme ça que le cactus essaie d'éliminer
on n'a pas de cactus qui est natif de
chez nous tous ils viennent du mexique
essentiellement donc l'histoire a
commencé avec un color une histoire de
color c'est le rouge parfum de perfect
raid
je vous conseille de lire ce bouquin si
vous le trouvez pas ce que l'histoire de
cactus est une histoire donc pire
d'espionnage et surtout la recherche de
la couleur du désir ce rouge parfait que
vous voyez ici que il est à plat là bas
dans cette salle est ce que vous vous
avez posé la question
ce rouge à lèvres que vous utiliser ils
viennent d'où ils viennent de cet
insecte parce que ce colorant et
hypoallergénique
elle est acceptée par l' oms comme le
meilleur colonnes tous les fonds de
teint que vous utilisez tout ça ça
vienne de cet insecte
donc c'est une information importante
donc vous voyez donc l'agro industrie
les jus l'école les confitures les
teintes tout ça sont à base de ce rouge
car maquiller le rouge parfait je passe
assez rapidement alors cette plante on a
parlé de robustesse et s'est libéré de
la résilience
le terme résilience qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire être capable de
tomber à genoux puis se relever et
continuer le chemin et le cactus et un
d'une plante résiliente
et je veux vous les jeunes que vous
soyez résilient ne vous découragez pas
vous pouvez échoué le premier jour où la
première tentative la deuxième la
troisième mais continuait résilience
c'est le terme qu'il faut résilience on
a vu des plantes de cactus pendant trois
années de sécheresse
on estime qu'ils sont complètement mort
puis dès les premières pluies
obs ils reprennent sans aucun problème
soyez content ce type de plantes comme
ce type de cactus je reviens à mon
environnement arrête mon réinventons que
que jeune chercheur était j'ai commencé
cette histoire en 1985 était de trouver
la plante qui est capable de pousser et
de produire dans un environnement aride
si la plante merak en bout et avec le
cactus je trouve que c'est mon candidat
préféré pourquoi parce qu'il est facile
à établir
vous souhaitez une raquette elle pousse
aucun problème une dure longtemps
plusieurs années des décennies il
produit des fruits et plein d'autres
choses et surtout il est verte ou le pas
il a des utilisations nombreuses je vais
vous donner quelques exemples pour l'iss
pour illustrer mon propos il y à 1600
espèces
ne croyez pas que les insultes cactus
lit dans ce qui se passe il ya des
dizaines de variétés
donc c'est vraiment un énorme trésor ou
est ce qu'on trouve le cactus
aujourd'hui essentiellement on est on en
reste du brésil où toute la production
laitière est basé sur la cactus en
tunisie
six cent mille ha si énorme en afrique
du sud en algérie au maroc donc là où il
ya la réalité est là le cactus
je passe là du sud en 1993 it et à dans
une ville au mexique à la ville de donc
deux et on était dans un café avec un
groupe de chercheurs italiens argentins
chiliens x intel
et on s'est dit pourquoi on ne crée pas
un réseau autour du cactus l'idée était
bonne on s'est adressé aux différentes
agences avec beaucoup de lobbying et de
conviction et de ténacité la fao nous a
hébergés et on a créé ce réseau afin au
cactus depuis 1993 et il continue en
2000 on m'a élu comme le coordinateur
général de réseau et j'ai fait ça
pendant 14 ans pendant 14 ans j'ai
sillonné la planète tous les continents
je les ai visité à par l'australie ce
que l'australie c'est interdit
d'introduire le cactus une vingtaine de
pays à peu près ont adhéré à ce réseau
je me suis déplacé pour former les gens
pour leur montrer tous les avantages de
ce cactus etc
les utilisations les applications vous
voyez tous les points jaunes que vous
avez là sur la carte
ce sont les pays où j'ai introduit cette
plante dont l'histoire a commencé dans
un café ils sont vos comme ça les
affaires se font en dehors des condors
des arcs est formel des exemples en
mauritanie dans la ville de nouakchott
on a donné à chaque famille une raquette
pour qu'ils font des jardins familiaux
c'est formidable ça marche on les vit
aussi en ethiopie en ethiopie j'ai une
histoire une ong
mam ce format c'est pour les femmes
célibataires les mères-célibataires donc
on leur a donné des dons qu'on les a
formés à transformer le cactus et de
vendre les produits et elles vivent avec
ça c'est des exemples que je vous cite
très rapidement en inde et au pakistan
aussi on a introduit avec des
difficultés au pakistan parce que
souvent ils à la confusion entre le a
comme qui est la plante donc que les
gens dans l'enfer consomment et les eaux
fort biya au fort bien et caqueta sien
c'est pas les choses donc il a fallu les
convaincre que nous parlons de choses
qui sont totalement différentes
des exemples maintenant de l'histoire du
succès le pérou au sud du pérou dans le
désert de mémoire d'homme on n'a pas vu
on n'a pas vu de pluie seulement il ya
qu un peu d'eau qui descendent dans la
fonte des neiges des andes
les gens ont planté de façon intensive
c'est pas pour la production de fruits
mais pour la production de cet insecte
de ce rouge qui tous donc de ce rouge
carmin la raquette
une fois attaqué ils font du compost
qu'elle injecte de nouveau dans le sable
les ont transformés totalement la nature
le cactus vous le connaissez tous si
pour l'alimentation de bétail si je vous
donne des exemples de la tunisie de
brésil de l'ethiopie cetera
souvent c'est le travail des femmes de
le couper en frites donc en morceaux et
pour faciliter la chose on a fabriqué
des machines ici localement gêne aux
entrepreneurs pour couper pour alléger
la charge de travail chez les femmes et
les enfants le fruit je réussis le roi
des fruits thank foot il n'ya pas mieux
que le cactus parce que les très riches
en antioxydants et en vitamine c
on sucre etc et il faut le traiter comme
un fruit entier comme la pomme comme la
poire et surtout le packaging la
présentation cet extrait tout ça c'est
des opportunités de business
ça c'est des affaires les noms pallice
la consommation de la gêne de de la
jeune raquette les gens rigolent mais
c'est vous c'est vous voyagez dans
certains pays comme le mexique par
exemple c'est dans les plats de tous les
jours on fait des salades ont fait des
plats cuisinés etc
ça s'appelle être non pas les 2 c les
jeunes raquettes
voyez ici c'est un attelage d'un marché
donc au mexique
on a fait la même chose en ethiopie on
était en plus on les a formés parce
qu'ils ne connaissent pas
a utilisé dans la cuisine et ils ont
introduit les jeunes raquettes dans le
plat quotidien un restaurant un
restaurant fameux et le bamboo dans la
ville d'avesnes au cuba où tout le menu
est à base de produits de cactus et j'en
passe ici al les produits à valeur
ajoutée élevée
il l'a c'est le domaine maintenant il
faut vraiment mettre le paquet parce que
là on peut gagner de l'argent je vous
donner quelques exemples de produits la
poudre de raquette la poudre de raquette
il y a un peu monté des industries
facilement de séchage au soleil en
l'utilisant c'est un produit qui très
demandé moi je reçois tout le temps des
emails ou est-ce que je peux
m'approvisionner en bordure de la
raquette la peau des raquettes et les
mises en capsules est utilisé pour pour
traiter ou bien pour déminer donc le
niveau de diabète ou bien aussi pour
améliorer le transit etc
c'est un produit qui est très
commercialise ça c'est la peau de la
requête
j'en passe vous voyez ça c'est des
exemples de produits commerciaux
il y avait une société en tunisie qui a
travaillé sur ça je passe les liqueurs
les jus des vins à partir de cactus ben
y en a plein les le fait de se déplacer
dans le supermarché et vous allez voir
et à chaque fois que vous voyez un
drapeau vous voyez l'origine donc de
produits la tunisie le mic et le mexique
les etats-unis et le maroc
l'huile donc des pépins qui se vend
actuellement à 700 $ le litre
donc c'est vraiment un chrono on a en
tunisie une entreprise ou deux qui font
ça et ça marche
[Musique]
bon ça c'est des exemples de prix des
huiles dans le monde
les applications médicinales à deux mots
sur les applications médicinales dans la
mode ici donc j'ai les indiens ça a été
utilisée tout le temps par exemple pour
les blessures en tant que cataplasme
ceux connus même chez nous aussi reconnu
il y à des équipes de recherche une
équipe en italie une équipe en argentine
une équipe aux états unis et une équipe
à neuf en allemagne maintenant je
travaille sur les applications
médicinales un large une large gamme
donc de deux mots si vous voulez qu'on
peut traiter avec le cactus que ce soit
le fruit ou la raquette mais
essentiellement là je vous cite un ou
deux exemples le traitement des ulcères
c'est une trouvaille italienne vous
consommez la raquette uniquement ça ça
vous ça vous évitera les ollières
l'hyperglycémie aussi c'est c'est un
flux les américains ont montré avec des
tests effectués dans les cliniques donc
chez les humains que on peut contrôler
on peut on peut bloquer le cancer du col
de l'utérus par des extraits donc obtenu
à partir de la raquette et j'en passe
donc c'est un monde
c'est un domaine énorme un exemple qui
m'a toujours plu si le sud du maroc au
sud donc d'agadir une coopérative de
femmes de 150 femmes se sont remis
ensemble et alfort alpha briques du jus
de confiture etc
elles font vivre de 150 familles et
c'est très innovant c'est très très
encourageant
il ya aussi à côté d'eux donc la garder
et pour le maroc c'est une politique
ils ont installé pour la première fois
au niveau du monde
un cac topol sur 25 hectares où les
industries la recherche tout ça ensemble
pour la promotion de quatre puces le don
le cadre 2 du plan maroc vert
15 coopérative ont été financés pour la
transformation des produits de catus et
dites-vous une chose faite de lobbying
donc que vous avez le pouvoir politique
derrière vous ça peut aller voulait
convaincre réussie vous donne un exemple
le roi du maroc qui inaugure une
plantation de cactus si t'en guerre qui
ne se déplace pas souvent mais il avait
17 ans il a donné un boost donc à tous
les promoteurs et les industriels merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]